here to respond to that rather ominous
message his mad slap chairman of the
American Conservative Union Rahim Qasim
fellow at the American principles
project and Raymond Arroyo Fox News
contributor Raymond today some of the
20/20 Dems they try to like back away a
little bit from these obviously anti
religious freedom statements made at
that equality townhall but is this
backing away or really credible well I'm
not sure it is Laura because every one
of them supports something called the
Equality Act Speaker Pelosi proposed
this last March essentially it would
give RuPaul more federal protections
than the Little Sisters of the Poor now
let me qualify that okay this is an
anti-discrimination piece of legislation
that exalts a sexual identity gender
preference above just about anything
else
and there are real-world implications
hospitals that refuse to perform certain
gender reassignment surgeries they could
be shut down the religious grounds there
are no religious exemptions under the
Equality Act when you talk about
orphanages when you when you start
talking about kids who think they're
transgender the parental rights could be
taken away from parents if they deny
these kids certain hormonal treatments
or surgical treatments and as I
mentioned the Little Sisters of the Poor
Laura they have been battling the Obama
care registration with not a legislation
it was just a rule that force them to
deny their own conscience and pay for
abortifacients and contraceptives
they're still battling that in court and
Obama signed this so this is everyone to
understand tonight and this is so
important and I think a lot of people
aren't covering this but this is
actually where there is a real skin in
the game for everyone match laugh yeah
this is this is not hyperbole this is
that sounds good to call something the
Equality Act by likes but like so many
other pieces of legislation the
euphemistic language doesn't capture
what's in the details yeah and what it
really was was empowerment to the trial
bar to be able to go after the Catholic
Church and Christian churches and shut
them down because here's where we are
Lord today we are to the point where it
bado says you can't really be a church
if you discriminate and that's what he
said and that's what he
and what beta was fine with is
discriminating against believers and
people of faith in this country in every
conceivable way when you say you're
going to take away the tax exemption to
the church and you're not going to allow
institutions like the University of
Notre Dame to receive any kind of
federal benefit for their students or
any campus that's absolute
discrimination let me tell you I say
this this next campaign it's not just
about socialism it's about secularism
and there's a and there's a combination
of the two
socialism yes it's bad economics but
it's about something more fundamental
they don't respect your right to have
your own beliefs and to make your own
decisions in your home they think your
beliefs Judeo it's Judeo it's Christian
it's Muslim I mean he was very explicit
and when they say osberto is an outlier
he is not an outlier AOC is as close to
being a thought leader and the Democrat
Party as there exists today Rahim this
isn't just about the promotion of
secularism let's be very clear about
this this is cancelling Christianity
that's what's going on here this is
canceling traditional values even
amongst Jewish families against Muslim
families but promote primarily we know
what they're coming after here and this
goes back interestingly to about 2005 in
its latest iteration George Soros
sponsored a conference at Yale it was
called the new rehabilitating the
Constitution they thought they had it
locked up and that by 2020 it was called
Constitution 2020 that they would be
able to change this whole thing to to
remove the undergirding of everything
that America is and when you think about
everything that's happened since that
conference and the people who were there
who then were in the Obama
administration you like your doctor you
can keep your doctor why we're not
coming after your guns
why look at this now you know gay
marriage was the end of it and we're not
going to go any further like Obama said
he was against gay marriages anyway he
admitted it was they admitted it was a
lie Americans have a really stark choice
in the next election it's do you trust
the people who have consistently now
lied to you time and time again about
incursions into your private life into
your children's lives into the fact that
as Raymond was saying earlier that now
this equality Act you'll have you'll
have young men running again running
track against young girls in school
happening all over my high school in
Glastonbury Connecticut is a huge huge
issue this is I mean so again people
want to say we don't like this tweet or
that tweet or Trump's tone it should
have said that okay at some point it's a
choice Raymond it's a choice between
religious liberty free expression the
First Amendment the Bill entire Bill of
Rights frankly they want to have it
we're gonna get into this next segment
they want to hold the whole tribunal to
kick a president out of office in secret
okay this runs roughshod over every
constitutional principle it just doesn't
make political sense the Democrats this
didn't really get covered in August the
Democratic National Committee they voted
on a proclamation to exalt venerate
those with no religious affiliation
basically people who are agnostic or
atheistic do they think this endears
them in any way to the the base of
religious voters who are in Trump's camp
try to win those people over instead
they've built their own wall and it's a
wall that pushes religious people aside
and religious expression even further
outside what they consider the
mainstream this is political suicide for
the Democratic Party I don't know why
they would do this but this line of talk
and supporting the Equality Act I don't
see how it ends well politically for
them in a national race well it means
that Donald Trump has that make this a
central issue Matt hit on that it's this
is this is women moms these are people
across the board they just wanna be able
to raise their kids with their own
values but they're told that they're
evil and they're discriminatory and
they're terrible people and they're all
the other things that they're told and I
think after a while people don't like
that like I'm just living my life leave
me alone you do love your life the way I
want don't cram down your values to me
by the way Matt Korey Booker said he
would use the federal government to
target schools that resist this agenda
watch
that allow people to use the bathrooms
that conforms with their gender identity
but we cannot stop there we must use our
Department of Justice and our Department
of Education Civil Rights Division to go
after schools that are denying people
equal rights and equal protections now
Matt more people are seeing the CNN Town
Hall on this show but it's important
it's important we're playing this for a
reason most people didn't watch this
this is where the party is going using
government as a weapon against the
people not to make the people's lives
better
it started with Obama spying on
reporters sending FCC lawyers into
newsrooms then it went to the DC
government asking for the sermons of
pastors to see if there was like hate
speech and now you have cory booker who
is literally running to be the president
united states saying he's gonna use the
DOJ to go against the american people
who have the same beliefs that george
washington had and our founders would be
considered what today in this democrat
party with what he campaign and what he
said we're red state of evolution or
united states right no no no we are now
they they want to just just be blue
state America
red state America if you have to die in
a bunch of opioid addiction that's just
too bad like just we don't really care
about you and if there's a home invader
coming to your house beta O'Rourke wants
you to have a Greta Thun burg approved
paper straw peashooter instead of a gun
to be able to take out home invaders
that's where this is there and there's
dishonest moments in the media lately
this is one of them Elizabeth Warren had
a viral moment at last week's town hall
after an audience member asked this
question the supporter approaches you
and says senator I am old-fashioned and
my faith teaches me that marriage is
between one man and one woman what is
your response well I'm gonna assume it's
a guy who said that and I'm gonna say
then just marry one woman
assuming you can find one I mean Raymond
I mean it turns out the questioner of
course you knew it was a choreographed I
think we all knew it was so obviously a
plant someone named Morgan Cox actually
a big Warren donor ok Washington Times
saying he's twice reached the legal max
of $2,700 donations to the Senate
campaign of Warren and her presidential
campaign so well I wasn't you know they
they pulled this off this little scheme
and seeing him guess was didn't know
about it was fine about it or Jeff
Zucker was applauding at whatever it was
a cute response there were a lot of cute
responses but let me lay it out for the
American people what's at stake there is
a rich religious social service network
in this country they serve the homeless
they they're educational leaders there
they have hospitals we are risking
shutting all of those down and the
orphanages have already gone out of
business hospitals are endangered and I
just read a case a man identifying as a
woman wanted access to a woman's
homeless shelter they turned him down
he's continually suing them trying to
get access to the place what do you
think they're gonna eventually do either
shut down or give up because of the
litigation this is what the Equality Act
in this vision being put forward could
lead us to it's a bad end bad for
America bad for those looking and need
help on the streets tonight across the
board this conversation is critical for
the election next year these are the
issues that must not be skirted
people have to have the guts to talk
about them they go right to parental
rights guys thank you so much tonight
and coming out